ladies and Gentlemen people of the world
wherever you are today is a very
exciting day um we've we've talked about
him on the show a handful of times I
would consider him part of the lore of
the show ladies and gentlemen Make some
noise at home in your car wherever one
only car top oh hello everybody hi I
like that you you mentioned me before
was it all good wasn't it it it worries
you right yeah no oh we talking about
all the time it was but I will say some
people entry point to you was your
wardrobe malfunction on Tik Tok do you
remember this oh God no oh God was it
like my wiener yes yeah it's like
bouncing around yeah yeah yeah well
that's a good
introduction a bad introduction now they
know you're working yeah I can had work
I mean right but hell yeah man thank God
I have a big one yeah yeah yeah thank
God cuz right then itd be like oh you
see them dance around the town yeah it's
like this little no I actually have a
super
this is very random because two things
one my mom would always reference your
movie CH uh chairman of the board okay
um but she'd always do the b o r d and
she would use that to roast my dad so if
my dad was telling a boring story she'
just call it out chairman of the board
yeah she go chairman of the board yeah
and she'd laugh at him yeah we did that
we did that on the set I think I mean we
were kind of privy to it I mean you
first day I think was said with chairman
of the board as in board not board you
know yeah cuz uh you know filming a move
for 2 months yeah but uh it was fun a
fun experience and of course you know
you're ready to get all the crap you
know because you're katop and your film
so it wasn't like I wasn't a shocked
they were going to rip me apart yeah
when did you make that film how many
years ago God I don't even remember 90
something something 90 yeah it was a
minute ago do you remember how old you
were when you made
it uh H 20s something late 20s yeah oh
yeah so I I I didn't know what I was
doing I had no clue like I even told
them that yeah that I didn't and they're
like you know ready said and I'm like
you know I don't know what I'm doing and
they're like yeah good and action like I
I don't know what I'm
doing well and they just they just you
it turned out okay because we you know
the more we got into the more you took
you know because I do standup so standup
is way different than movies in every
aspect of it and uh you know Larry
Miller was a brilliant comic that he was
on the one of the cast members and he he
took me aside one day we were watching
the dailies and he says you want to see
can I give you a little tip and I said
please give me anything and he brought
me in and he said you see how you're
when you're doing this let me show you
this scene we did today so he did
something with his his um eyebrow just
he just by moving his eyebrow got the
got the laugh it was the punchline by
watching that little one move as opposed
to me you know jumping around and trying
to but but then again there was always
props and so I'm I was part of it I had
to be kind of bigger than life silly
because I'm jumping around with big
props and surfboards and all this
but the actual scenes where you had to
be serious he learn I learned a lot like
this scene with Jack Warden I mean it
was a kind of a cool scene yeah yeah I
mean for all the um you know whatever
[__] people used to give you you did a
lot of crazy yes yes it was I mean know
it's awesome actually the the scene
where the woman flushes the toilet yes
so it's funny cuz my cousins they show
like they showed me this movie I think I
was maybe like six or seven we were all
about the same age and they like they
love the movie they're like you got to
watch chairman of the board so we watch
chairman of the board and they that
scene for some reason was like stamped
in my mind right and I'm not
exaggerating for the rest of my life
I've always had this thought that while
I'm taking a shower someone's going to
storm the bathroom and flush the toilet
and turn the water cold so in a weird
way that's the impact oh good my life is
just permanent fear in the shower dude
do you remember like just for the people
listening that aren't familiar like with
your entire career do you remember like
one of your first performances ever like
could you tell that absolutely yeah yeah
it was at the rat skeller in the uh in
the college um like Library they had
this little room off the side and I said
they had they serve beer at night and uh
there was a little stage and I said you
know is it cool if I go up there and do
uh you know comedy and they said great
do you know how to do I said I don't
know how to do it but you know if you
mind doing it so I just went up there
and just started telling jokes yeah I
mean like George Carlin jokes and and
Richard Pryor jokes and you know jokes
that had been set before not my stuff
yeah and it was just the comfort of
doing it and people laughing that I I
said I really like this and then uh a
couple more times came by they said they
would ask me actually hey do you want to
on Wednesdays you want to make that like
comedy night so I said sure So every
Wednesday I would have com then started
becoming a little more popular and all
the the kids would come and drink beers
and I'd put on a little show and then
would start to slowly progress into um
my own material after doing all those
jokes and so I started thinking of uh a
way to to come up my own jokes so my
first prop was a uh a neighborhood crime
watch sign okay and um I had stolen it
it was on my dorm so I I just ripped it
off my door and I walked in I said sorry
I'm late I was in the neighborhood and
held up the sign and I said how good is
our crime watch if they not watching the
signs and everybody laughing and they
was like well this clever and funny and
you know it's kind of RA you stole the
signs so there's a lot of elements that
made it funny yeah and it was smart you
know it's like smart like how good is
our crime Mar and so um then I started
thinking I need to have more signs maybe
like think the so I went through the
city of bokeh and I literally said
that's a funny sign too because it was
about a train horn is it no train horn
between these hours and I'm like that's
the hours you need the train horn
because you can't see the TR you need to
hear it and so I pulled that one down
and then I took there was a main the
main road that went through Booker home
was called butts road yeah so I said you
got to get that one and just say this is
where all the [__] live yeah so it
was just started to become a little um a
sign bit you know and I had all these
like 15 different signs slow children at
play if you looked at the sign to this
day they have a stick figure with no
feet I said no wonder they're slow they
don't have any feet right so it was all
stuff people had seen you know they're
like oh that's funny see that sign every
day I never put those two two together
yeah so it's kind of coming up with the
things that were um and people that
influenced me in comedy where like
people that wrote like George Carlin
would kind of come up with that or
Gallagher like a a a gag where you we'd
see but was also clever like you can
make yourself not like not like just
holding up this coffee cup it would have
to be something that would be you know
the cup would have to do something was
it you know I mean I'm sure that was a
pretty crazy moment to be acknowledged
by Carlin cuz didn't you know like if
you're saying in college you say his
material is like right you know right
just to give it a shot and then you
eventually you know his name comes out
of his his face I mean that must have
been insane for you I show it in my show
every night I do thing about been
influenced in my life and it was a
tradition my friends but always sit on a
couch just like this and we'd watch the
HBO special every time it aired yeah and
so my buddies went all sit down and we'd
hit play and we'd watch the George Car
special and then sure enough we're just
watching it and he says you know who
packed your bags he says you didn't pack
your bags he says no katop pack my bags
and I'm sitting on my my friend's like
what the right the only one with the
boner you know so I'm like sorry fellas
I had no idea to say boner let's make
that clear back that's right everyone's
knows about it now so I can't lie what
it was
everywhere so so that was it's it's
still when I still watch it when I watch
it nightly it's still it's still
exciting because it's like George Carlin
you know saying your name when you first
get into the business you know you
you're watching him and thinking about
people like that that are mentors and
you get he says your name it's yeah it's
a cool moment because and everyone you
know would lie if they said they didn't
get excited that their Mentor mentioned
their name
so